bonjour à tous aujourd'hui un tout
nouveau concept on va parler d'un sujet
en trois minutes dans trois minutes tech
c'est parti on lance le compteur trois
minutes tech pour parler du elric 0 de
sony la nouvelle caméra la nouvelle
action cannes hyper compact de sony
alors action can oui et non c'est une
action cam un appareil photo ne s'est
pas une grosse est relativement
différent elle a un appareil photo qui
est très compact mais qui n'est pas des
formes en elle un objectif de 24 mm une
ouverture de 4 un capteur cmos exmor r
sc mauvaise de call of duty 3 megapixels
au dos un écran de 3 8 cm de diamètre un
ratio de 4 par 3 une mise au point
minimale de 50 cm côté dimensions il est
très compact 59 mm part de 29,8 et une
hauteur de 45 minimes et elle pèse 110 g
côté photo la sensibilité va 225 à 25600
iso et pour la vidéo elle va de 125 à
12800 iso
elle a une batterie de 700 millions
terreur écoute autonomie on traite entre
35 à 60 minutes à feu moyen
côté photos bref vous permet de faire
bien sur des prises de vues en jpeg et
en rouge jusqu'à 16 images par seconde
il vous permet d'enregistrer en full hd
jusqu'à 240 images par seconde et en 4k
usd à 30 images par seconde mais par
contre pour enregistrer en 4k il vous
faut un enregistreur externe côté slow
motion vous pouvez filmer jusqu'à 1000
images par seconde et par contre ce qui
est génial c'est la possibilité de
pouvoir filmer en est selon lui cette
caméra à une prise hdmi et une prise usb
pour pouvoir se recharger vous pouvez
l'immerger jusqu'à 10 mètres si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez rajouter une coque
pour pouvoir aller jusqu'à 100 m elle
résiste aux chutes jusqu'à deux mètres
et un écrasement jusqu'à 200 kg points
négatifs vous n'avez pas de
stabilisation vous pouvez l'utiliser
seul
si vous souhaitez les shoots et faire
des vidéos et une seule mais vous pouvez
l'utiliser avec d'autres eric 0 vous
pouvez piloter jusqu'à 5 et 6 0 avec
l'appli mobile sony plaisent memory
morheim avec la télécommande
f awp afp pour les piloter jusqu'à 15 mx
ça c'est vraiment génial je voulais
faire un bullet time comme dans matrix
avec 15 axial car vous allez vous
régaler par contre côté prix cela vous
coûte relativement cher côté tarifs
avaient vendu un tout petit peu moins de
850 euros
lorsque vous faites
vidéo vous souhaitez faire votre point
très très nette un objet ou sur une
personne tôt sur des films et vous avez
le système focus pythie vous allez
pouvoir zoomer pour faire le point sur
une personne en particulier et à voir
l'image la plus nette la plus fine
possible côté intérêts point positif
c'est effectivement une action car elle
a une prise micro ou puissiez
effectivement brancher vos micros et
avoir une bonne qualité audio alors
normalement lorsqu'on utilise sans micro
le son est pas dégueu alors ce n'est pas
un sont professionnels ce serait pour
moi une petite caméra supplémentaire ou
c'est pour utiliser pour des docus pour
un making of pour avoir des plans de
coupe on actionne cam pourquoi pas
grassement là il vous faudra forcément
un stabilisateur a priori sony
travaillerait sur un stabilisateur pu
croiser sur la rn102 par ces
spécifications techniques de part son
prix ça en fait une caméra
professionnelle et le poil plus plus
plus c'est le mode s love pour
travailler vraiment la qualité de vos
images
le slow motion jusqu'à 1000 images par
seconde vous allez retrouver en gros une
rx ans dans un tout petit format
maintenant les points négatifs il n'y a
pas de stabilisation donc si vous tenez
à la main si vous le mettez sur un
casque vous allez avoir une image qui
bouge énormément
la 4 car la capca qui va se démocratiser
énormément dans les années à venir le
full hd est amené à disparaître
forcément vont augmenter en qualité si
vous voulez de la quête cas il vous faut
forcément un enregistreur expérience ça
veut dire du matériel supplémentaire ça
veut dire forcément des coûts
supplémentaires pour voilà un peu tout
ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui sur 7
eric 0 en 3 minutes dites moi ce que
vous en pensez est ce que c'est une
caméra qui pourrait vous intéresser à ce
que vous faites de la vidéo si oui quel
matériel utilisé vous est-ce que vous
utiliser du matériel sony s vous a déjà
utilisé la rx en est ce que là éric 0
pourrait vous tenter qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce format compact est ce que
vous utilisez vous une go pro est ce que
vous pensez que cette caméra pourrait
remplacer la gopro est ce que vous
pensez vraiment que ce sont deux
produits complètement différent vous
marquez tout sans commentaire on en
parle on se retrouve très très vite pour
un prochain format de trois minutes tech
dites moi ce que vous pensez de ce
format de vidéo est ce que ça va vous
plaît je vous invite à me laisser un
petit commentaire
a lake et cette vidéo est à vous abonner
passera toujours toujours toujours plus
de contenu pour parler de la tech merci
et à très bientôt